they are scientists creators academics
the people who are forming our future
they see Limitless benefits to the work
in front of them but potentially
Limitless danger too their statement on
artificial intelligence is short and it
is Stark mitigating the risk of
Extinction from AI should be a global
priority alongside other societal scale
risks such as pandemics and nuclear war
it may be absurd
certainly cliche to reach for the
science fiction as we wonder what our
future might hold but the question seems
to be how much of this could soon be
fact when it comes to the risk to
humanity the signatories of the
statement want as much air time as
possible to warn of their concerns the
day might come with
capacity vastly exceeds that of humans
and humans lose the ability to stay in
control of what it is that the human
that the machine is is
um seeking to optimize and at the time
it seemed in the far future
now it it it it may be as it were
Galloping towards us
the Netflix series Black Mirror offers a
speculative fiction and on society's
challenges it is often proving prescient
but this frightening dystopia a world
where we've made robots that do the
thinking make the decisions was based on
the work of Boston Dynamics
and look how far they've come in a
decade from this in 2010
to this
this year but the people behind this
have clear moral policy pledges signed
with other robotic companies
the debate is prompting top level policy
discussion the AI clearly can bring
massive benefits to the economy and
society and you've seen that recently
whereas helping paralyze people to walk
discovering new antibiotics but we need
to make sure that this is done in a way
that is safe and is secure yet don't
assume that the AI Community is speaking
with one voice on all this it is not
people need to calm down Professor Pedro
Dominguez has spent his career studying
AI so if we want to make AI safe the
best way to do it is to make it more
intelligent because it's stupidity
that's dangerous not intelligence the
way that people have is that AI will get
too intelligent and we will not be able
to control it but intelligence and
control are completely different things
we can have an infinitely intelligent AI
that we still control very well
artificial intelligence is already
fundamentally part of our Lives the
debate over how we live with it how we
control it has only just begun Mark
Stone Sky News in Washington